the media lie about systemic police
racism the white house the media and
lebron james target a police officer for
shooting a black teenager who is trying
to stab
another black teenager and the biden
administration cracks down on police
departments i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with vpn so should you
visit expressvpn.com
ben well we begin today with the simple
fact that for many in the media
for virtually the entire democratic
party the police are the enemy
the police are the bad guys the police
are systemically racist
and every incident of police violence in
america that involves
a white police officer and a black
suspect
any incident that goes wrong or even in
which the police do their duty
all of those incidents are just
emblematic of systemic police racism
this is a point that i made with regard
to the derek chauvin trial
whatever you think about chauvin whether
you think that he was guilty of second
in third degree murder and manslaughter
which is
sort of odds and second and third degree
murder have different elements but even
if you believe that he was guilty
of all of the elements of all of those
murders and all of those charges even if
you believe all of that
there was one charge that derek chovin
was convicted of and the entire system
was convicted of and that was systemic
american racism
and the argument was entirely circular
derek chovan there was no evidence shown
that he killed george floyd because
george floyd was black
none not not iota not a cintilla the
prosecution never even
made that argument and yet derek chovin
was used as the
perfect example case a case one a
exhibit 1a in the american police are
systemically
racist argument and the
the the idea was that because of people
like derek shoven the american police
are systematically racist also we have
no evidence that derek shoving was
actually a racist
so what that means is that american
police being systemically racist
that's why he did this it's perfectly
circular derek chovin is systemically
racist because the system is
systemically racist which is
systemically racist because derek chovan
is systemically racist
at no point you actually have to show
racism anywhere in here and that's why
the derek shoving story was a national
story of course because otherwise it's
just a local crime story
otherwise it's just a story of a cop
acting in a brutal way
and that's not a national news story but
the idea from the entire media
from the white house where the president
and co-president spoke
the other day the entire story from the
left in this country
is that every police department is built
along
the lines of derek chovin systemic
racism isn't just part of our policing
it's part of our entire way of life
and this is how you have cbs news
featuring the racial grifter ibrahim x
kendi
talking about how the derek chauvin
trial is just indicative of how deeply
racist
america is and he says that it's not
just derek chovan who's on trial it was
all of america that was on trial now you
know what i can guarantee you that the
vast majority of police officers
in america are not engaging in this sort
of activity in which
derek chauvin was allegedly engaging
this is but everyone is guilty and
that's the entire argument the entire
argument
is that all of america is guilty now the
fact that ibrahmax can is being featured
on national news is in and of itself
insane considering that ibrahmax kennedy
is an actual tyrant
he has suggested that there be a federal
department of anti-racism
an unelected body of people who are
capable of striking down
any law or regulation federal state or
local
that ends with inequality of outcome
which is just fascism
okay but ever max kenny is considered an
expert on race for the great reason
that he parrots in worse writing
the the ideas of derek bell and richard
delgado about critical race theory
and now he is considered a great thought
leader jack dorsey donated 10 million
dollars to his center for anti-racism
which to date has produced no serious
research
so here's ever mex kenny being featured
on cbs news and explaining
why the derrick chauvin trial is really
about systemic police racism and truly
about systemic american races more
broadly
chauvin is headed to jail but is america
headed to justice is justice convicting
a police officer
or is justice convicting america when
tens of millions of americans after
floyd's murder last year
took to the streets of nearly every
american town
we were convicting america justice is
opening the door to an anti-racist
future where american fear
is endangered where i no longer live in
fear
where americans no longer live in fear
of me
justice has convicted america justice
has convicted america and that's what
the entire left wants and that is why
cbs news
is featuring ivor max kennedy saying
this cbs news
super objective stuff there from cbs
news pretty incredible by the way
nobody's afraid of
ibrah max kennedy as a human i'm afraid
of his ideas because his ideas are
tyrannical
and frightening and horrifying his ideas
are truly terrible
they are garbage racist ideas ever max
kenny is a person who has said that
discrimination of the past can only be
remedied by discrimination today
he is in fact a racist and then he uses
that under the guise of quote unquote
anti-racism
in order to push forward these bizarre
ideas of equity that involve
serious discrimination on the basis of
race of course the biden administration
has embraced this wholesale we know that
the biden administration is attempting
to teach ibramax candy type anti-racist
crap
in the public schools now according to
national review president biden's
department of education
has signaled its intent to impose the
most radical forms of critical race
theory on america's schools
very much including the 1619 project and
the so-called anti-racism of ibram x
kendi biden is obviously co-opting
conservatives interest in reviving
traditional us history and civics to
deliver its perfect opposite this is
according to stanley kurt's writing for
national review
biden's department of education has just
released the text of a proposed new rule
establishing priorities for grants in
american history and civics education
programs
that rule gives priority to grant
projects that incorporate
racially ethnically culturally and
linguistically diverse perspectives
the rule goes on to cite and praise the
1619 project as well as candy
as leading examples of the sorts of
ideas the biden administration wants to
spread now there are predictable effects
of the critical race theory ideas that
are now being fostered
in america's public schools that are
being pushed by the media and making
heroes of people
and profits of people like ibrahim x
kennedy and the predictable result
is a worse way of life for hundreds of
millions of americans
it is it is fostering lies about the
nature of what america is
is fostering lies about the nature of
america's police
in a second we're going to go through
some of the details about policing in
the united states
and the argument that america's police
are systemically racist we'll get to
that in just
one second first let us talk about a
simple fact if you're a responsible
human being you need life insurance for
your family it's just that simple if you
have people who are dependent on you god
forbid something should happen to you
they would lose you but they would also
lose your stream of income and that'd
make life
really really difficult this is why you
need life insurance the best place to
get life insurance
policygenius.com policy genius can help
you compare top insurers in one place
and save 50
or more on life insurance once you find
your best option the policy genius team
will set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
and you can feel good knowing your
family has financial protection
getting started is super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes to
find your best
price since their licensed agents work
for you not the insurance companies
there is zero hassle
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process policy genius will
take care of everything
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews on trustpilot and
google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius the
comparison tool the handling of
paperwork the unbiased advice are
totally free to use
policy genius can promise you won't
leave their website feeling like a fool
you could say 50
or more by comparing life insurance
quotes feel good knowing that if
something happens your loved ones will
be taken care
of go to policygenius.com to get started
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important to get it
right
okay so let's go through some of the
fact about policing in the united states
of america
there are literally tens and tens and
tens of millions of encounters between
the police and civilians every year
in the united states and there has yet
to be solid evidence that the police are
seeking out black men
to harm black men there's just a report
that came out from the department of
justice bureau of justice statistics in
it found quote there is no statistically
significant difference by race between
how likely people were to commit serious
violent crimes
and how likely they were to be arrested
in other words the data suggested that
police officers and sheriff's depart
and sheriff's deputies focus on
criminals actions not their race
see one of the things that you'll see
very often in the media is they'll say
look how many more black people than
white people are arrested
well that makes sense if more black
people than white people per capita are
committing crimes
to to present those statistics without
any underlying
information about the reports that are
being made about criminal activity is
absolutely ridiculous
it's like saying the nba is unbelievably
racist look how heavily black the nba is
you're like no
that's just the number of people per
capita who are really good at basketball
okay to say that the the racial
statistics with regard to crime are
irrelevant to the racial statistics with
regard to arrest
is to be a fool you're leaving out the
chief confound which is the underlying
activity
in other words if 60 of reports of a
particular crime
are about black people and 60 of the
arrests are of black people that's not
the fault of the cops
if ten percent of the reports are about
black people and sixty percent of the
arrests are
black people then it starts to look a
lot like systemic racism obviously
heather mcdonald reported just a couple
of years ago in 2019
police officers fatally shot a thousand
and four people most of whom were armed
or otherwise dangerous
african americans were about a quarter
of those killed by cops a ratio that has
remained stable since 2015.
that share of black victims is less than
what the black crime rate would predict
since police shootings are a function
of how often officers encounter armed
and violent suspects in 2018 the latest
year for which such data had been
published
african americans made up 53 of known
homicide offenders in the united states
and committed about 60
of robberies though they are 13 of the
population
it is true that police officers are 18.5
times more likely to be killed by a
black male than an unarmed black male is
to be killed by the police
in august 2019 the national academy of
sciences published research showing
there was quote no significant evidence
of anti-black
disparity in the likelihood of being
fatally shot by police
and then as soon as heather mcdonnell
cited that stat the national academy of
sciences tried to pull down the actual
study
there's a widely publicized study in
july of 2016 from roland fryer of
harvard
university surveying over a thousand
police shootings finding that black
suspects are shot less often than white
suspects in comparable situations
a deadly force lab study from washington
state university found that the
participants were biased in favor of
black suspects in simulated threat
scenarios
in 2015 the doj analyzed the
philadelphia police department
found that white officers were actually
less likely than black or hispanic
officers to shoot unarmed black suspects
so in other words this notion that the
police are run through with white
supremacy
is a lie it is a lie but because that
lie is so common because it is so
crucial
to the systemic racism argument which
requires no evidence of actual systemic
racism it just requires that you not
understand the phrase it requires the
semantic overload
because when people on the left say
systemic racism most people just hear
racism
they just hear that racists exist
because here's the game that the left
plays it's a perfect
martin bailey argument they'll say
systemic racism you say okay i need
evidence that the system itself
is racist you have to show me where in
the regulations it is racist
or you have to show me where the
policies are designed to be racist
and then allah says no what we mean by
because you are saying that
that means that you don't understand
racism it means that you are in fact a
racist because racism does exist are you
denying that racism exists
no i'm not denying that racism exists
only a fool will deny that racism exists
i am denying that the police
pursue procedures that are designed to
harm black people more than they are
designed to harm white people or mexican
people or people of any other ethnicity
in any case all of this ties together in
the
generalized leftist belief that the
police are bad
black lives matter is not about black
lives it isn't they just don't care
about certain black lives period end of
story the only black lives that black
lives matter
cares about are ones that are ended by
the cops and it doesn't matter what the
circumstances of the death are
this is the proof positive today so
today's big
cop shooting story is a cop shooting
story out of columbus ohio
the headline from the washington post
fatal police shooting of black teenager
in columbus sparks a new outcry
now from that headline you would imagine
there's a black teenager who was walking
along the street
and a columbus police officer decided
just to gun down that black teenager
right
fatal police shooting of black teenager
in columbus sparks new outcry
here's the actual story body camera
footage from a columbus police officer's
fatal shooting of a black teenager
sparked outcry and protests from local
activists
national leaders and even the white
house on wednesday as it became the
latest in a string
of deadly videos documenting the final
moments of a person of color killed by
law enforcement
okay now as we are about to find out
that is missing you know the fact
pattern
it's missing the actual facts because
nobody in the media gives a bleep about
the facts
nobody on the left apparently i'm not
talking about liberals i'm talking about
the hard left
who are now driving the party boat here
no one gives a crap
about black lives that are not ended by
the cops they don't care about this
they don't care if a black person kills
another black person they do not care
in fact they it's not just they don't
care they're okay with that
so long as it means there are fewer
police officers on the street if there
are fewer police officers on the streets
and more black people get murdered
this is what they are stumping for this
is what they are actively rooting for
apparently
because here's what actually happened in
this story
again watch how far you have to go into
this washington post piece before you
actually get the fact pattern
paragraph one was all about the evils of
this columbus police officer
condemned by national leaders and local
activists in the white house paragraph
two the death of sixteen-year-old makia
bryant who was shot by officer nicholas
reardon on tuesday during an altercation
during an altercation guys it was just
an altercation comes as the nation is
undergoing a broad reckoning over police
brutality and racism
her name joins a long and growing list
of black people killed by police
officers and deadly interactions that
have sparked protests
and broad calls for justice okay that
was paragraph two
okay we still don't know the incident
all we know we've they're gradually
dripping out what actually happened
right because when it turns out that you
find out what happened
the cop wasn't just right the cop saved
a black girl
okay so paragraph one was it was really
bad cop shot a black person white house
hated it paragraph two was
the det there was an altercation that's
all we now know
and we know that this person's name has
now been added to the list
of tragedies in which a black person was
shot by a white cop
okay wait till i'll continue with the
story in just one second it's pretty
incredible
first let's talk about a simple fact you
want to feel safe and secure your house
you want to make sure that your family
feels safe and secure your house you
want to make sure that you know whether
somebody's dropping off groceries or you
just have a friend stopping by whether
you have lots of kids like i do running
around the property
you have an eye on them at all times
this is where ring devices come in
with ring you can keep an eye on your
home no matter where you are right from
your phone ring has hassle free easy to
install indoor and outdoor cams you'll
never miss a visitor you can keep those
packages and delivery safe with motion
detection you'll get notified even if
they don't ring the doorbell
if someone stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know there's
a special offer on the ring welcome kit
at ringgit.com forward slash ben
it comes with rings video doorbell 3 and
the chime pro don't wait get a special
offer on the ring welcome kit at
ring.com
today it comes with that ring video
doorbell three and the time pro it's the
perfect way to start
your ring experience head on over to
ring.com that is ring.com when my
family and i moved from california
terrible place to florida
the first thing we did with the ring
devices on our house we all feel safer
we all feel more secure and
i can keep an eye on my crazy kids who
are running around trying to hurt
themselves all the time
go check them out ring.com for the
special offer on the ring welcome kit
okay so now
we are we are fully two paragraphs into
the story and we still don't know
the facts surrounding the shooting of
michael bryant paragraph three
in a sign of how effective those how
effective those protests have been
in drawing attention to the issue of
police violence the details of the
shooting were swiftly briefed to
president biden
whose administration has pledged to
address systemic racism and overhaul
policing
okay that was paragraph three you still
don't know what the hell happened
paragraph four
the killing of sixteen-year-old michael
bryant by columbus police's tragic said
white house press secretary jen sackey
okay paragraph five as saki was drawing
a connection between brian's killing and
the broader trend of disproportionate
use of force against minorities by
police
officials in columbus sought to calm
tensions by quickly releasing
information about the incident
that's paragraph six i wish the hell it
hadn't happened
interim police chief michael woods told
reporters after releasing the footage
and the 911 calls the lead officers to
respond woods said the officer
has been with the department since
december of 2019 has been placed on
administrative leave
okay that is paragraph seven you notice
that we are now like halfway through the
story and you still
don't know what the hell happened in
this shooting
all you know is that a black girl got
shot and a white police officer did the
shooting you still don't know
it takes all the way until paragraph
nine before you actually get
to the facts of the shooting quote the
footage released wednesday shows a
chaotic scene
the officer identified as riordan
arrives during a physical altercation
involving several people
rearden who is white can be seen
emerging from his vehicle as bryant
appears to chase someone who falls onto
the sidewalk the team then turns towards
someone else wearing a pink sweatsuit
and takes a swing at her hand with what
appears to be a blade briefly visible in
her hand
the officer yells gets down multiple
times before firing four shots at the
girl leaving her sprawled
next to a car in the driveway she had a
knife she just ran
at her one officer says on the footage
another clip showed officer performing
cpr on bryant so um
this is a case where a girl was
attempting to stab
another girl and this was covered in
paragraph nine of the washington post
story paragraph nine
nbc news was even worse nbc news put up
the body cam footage
they took out the part with the knife
and they took out the part from the 911
call where somebody actually reported
that the girl had a knife in the first
place they just cut it out
the media are rooting for the cops to go
down
that is all this is the media are openly
rooting for this stuff right now
here's the edited here's the edited clip
from nbc news
police body cam video shows makaya
bryant's final moments
when a columbus ohio police officer
responding to a call
gets out of his car and seconds later
fatally shoots the 16 year old girl
officer nicholas reardon who joined the
force in december
of 2019 was responding to a 911
approaching a group of young people
in this driveway it wasn't just nbc news
cnn
there are growing questions according to
wolff blitzer about what just happened
in columbus
growing well now it seems to me that
once you know what happened
there actually should be lessening
questions should there not
there should be a decrescendo of
questioning considering that we now know
that the cop shot a black girl who's
attempting to stab another black girl
but here's the thing if the cop had
never shown up and makia bryant had
stabbed the other girl to death
nobody would have cared nobody would
have cared
nobody in the media nobody in black
lives matter not lebron james
not the white house they wouldn't have
given two dams about that girl's life
how do i know
how do i know i know that because it did
happen
okay in cincinnati ohio two days ago a
13 year old girl was stabbed to death
13 year old black girl was stabbed to
death by another 13 year old girl
this is not a national news story
because no one cares if a black person
stabs another black person to death and
they're both 13.
nobody cares if the cop had shown up and
shot
the 13 year old black girl who's
stabbing the other girl then it would be
a national news story about systemic
police racism
here's a story that actually matters
from cincinnati ohio because it turns
out
that the homicide statistics in black
america are
devastating are crippling the number of
black americans killed unarmed by the
police every year is under 20.
the number of black americans who are
killed in homicides every year is
thousands upon
thousands we were talking in the year
2019 alone
about 7 500 black americans were killed
in homicides the vast majority of those
people were killed by other black people
because most crime in america is
intra-racial
i mean seriously this true absurdity
that we are supposed to pay attention
only when you when a cop is involved
demonstrates that this is not about
saving black lives not in the slightest
it's about the reverse
it's about we don't care if more black
people get killed so long as we
dismantle the cops it is just anti-cop
hatred
here is this case from cincinnati ain't
nobody gonna pay attention to this
because it was just a
13 year old black girl whose life
mattered also but not to the media
because it wasn't ended by a cop
i held her i watched her as she died
i watched him all i could do was just
hold it
and hold it devastation heartache
loss i tried
i tried to stop the bleeding
are you devastated by that because you
should be devastated by that it turns
out that niara givens which is the name
of the girl who is stabbed
you should say her name much more often
than you say the name of the girl who
was attempting to stab another girl and
got shot by the police
now our givens didn't do anything she
was just stabbed to death but you don't
care about that in the media
that's not a national that's a local
crime story it's not a national news
story
it's just amazing but don't worry the
questions are growing in columbus not in
cincinnati in columbus here's wolf
blitzer talking about the growing
questions in columbus
we're also following developments in
columbus ohio where there are now
growing questions about the deadly
police shooting
of 16 year old african-american mikaya
bryant
police are releasing more body camera
video that appears to show bryant
wielding a knife
and officers warning her several times
to get down before she seems
to lunge at another girl and police
opened fire
okay the grunt growing seems to lunge
seems not not lunges
okay and and it was across the media it
was just lying about the case just lying
about it
outright pretty incredible msnbc's jason
johnson
he misleads about the case too because
that's what he does
the kia bryant a 16 year old girl in
columbus ohio
called the police for help an officer
was on the scene
and in 22 seconds he shot her dead an
honor roll student
who's making tick-tock videos on makeup
and hair
this hasn't stopped oh it was
yeah just makeup videos that's all she
was doing also attempting to stab
another girl with a knife
but other than that the same the same
the defenses are coming fast and furious
from people of makia bryant's activities
the tick-tock things again this is what
the media do they seize on one detail of
a particular case and then claim that
this has something to do with the case
right for trayvon martin it was the the
hoodie and the skittles
and for and for makia brian it's
tick-tock videos
that's irrelevant to why the cop shot
her the cop didn't shooter cause she was
making tick-tock videos he shot her
cause she was trying to stab another
girl
and it's across the media okay well
we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact you don't
really want to be going to the post
office
today i mean why would you want to go to
the post office any day post office is
great but you don't want to stand in
line and schlep all your packages there
instead
head on over to stamps.com stamps.com
allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer you
can send letters you can ship packages
you can pay a lot less with discounted
rates from usps
ups and more stamps.com has saved
businesses thousands of hours tons of
money
with stamps.com you get the services of
the post office and ups
all in one place plus you get big
discounts on mailing and shipping rates
here at daily wire we've been using
stamps.com since 2017.
there's no more wasting our time
stamps.com brings the services of the us
postal service and ups directly to your
computer
stamps.com it's a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices or an online seller
shipping out orders or even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class email anywhere you
want to send it once your mail is ready
just schedule a pick up or drop it off
stamps.com saves you time it takes you
money there's a reason we at dailywire
use stamps.com stop wasting your time
going to the post office go to
stamps.com instead no risk with my promo
code shapiro you get a special offer it
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and
digital scale no long term commitments
or contracts head on over to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage
type in shapiro that is stamps.com promo
code shapirostamps.com
never go to the post office again okay
so the defense is from the media of
makia bryant's activities and and the
attacks on the cops which is really what
it is much more about
those are coming fast and furious today
so make no mistake
this is not police this is not about
police officers behaving in ways that
violate the law this is not about
derek chauvin and whether derek showing
committed manslaughter or second degree
murder
this is about police officers just doing
it their jobs
okay now i'm going to show you the
actual body cam footage i think it's
important you actually see the body cam
footage
of what happened in this particular case
here's the actual body cam footage of
what happened in this particular case
because by all the narrative that i've
given you at this point
you would think that the cop did
something wrong the cop saved a black
girl's life that's what happened here
but he wasn't supposed to save the black
girl's life he was supposed to let mkia
bryant stab this other girl to death
and then he would have been doing his
job apparently because black lives
matter does not give a damn about black
lives
unless it also has to do with
dismantling the police that's the real
agenda
here is the body cam footage what's
going on
hey what's going on hey hey hey hey
get down get down get down
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that girl is coming out if you if
you screen cap it what you will see
from the body cam footage is makia
bryant lunging at the other girl with a
knife
you can see her do it i mean it's
horrifying footage that's a knife in her
hand
she has a knife in her hand she's about
to stab this other girl
in fact the woman who didn't get stabbed
this woman who's wearing the pink
bodysuit
she says later in the body cam footage
she was trying to stab me with a knife
here she was
she came out with a chill with a knife
earlier no she just that's what they got
that's why the police department
she came after me with a knife yeah so
she so he got her
but that woman whose life was just saved
by the cop her life apparently doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter if she'd been stabbed
to death right there on the sidewalk
wouldn't matter because makia bryant
made tick-tock videos and the cop is bad
because the cop is white and cops are
always bad
michael eric dyson of msnbc said that
you know the police
show more discretion when it's white's
wielding machetes again statistically
speaking more whites than blacks are
shot by the cops
and according to professor moustas at
john jay college police are more likely
to shoot a white suspect
who is a danger to them than a black
suspect but none of that matters there's
michael eric dyson lying
the police will not exercise discretion
will not
use a reduced sense of engagement
to preserve black life we see constantly
we see videos of white people wielding
machetes
chasing police people around a white man
with a gun
on his seat as the police extract their
revolvers from their holsters pointing
them at him
demanding he get out and he refuses to
and takes off
and they don't shoot him it's
unbelievable
it's just unbelievable i mean this is
it's not true
okay there's a lot of body cam footage
all body cam footage is by its very
nature anecdotal because it's a single
incident
all we have are data and the data do not
back up anything that michael eric dyson
is saying
right there none of that matters the
only thing that matters is that the cops
suck and they need to be gotten rid of
and if that means more
dead black people the media don't give
two dams about it it's unbelievable
you want to talk about systemic racism
the systemic racism of a media that does
not care if thousands of additional
black people die every year because the
cops aren't there to protect them
against people committing criminal acts
the media are responsible for that
the media are pushing that it's unreal
politicians are pushing this by the way
msnbc's joy reid who is just
a font of utter insanity on a constant
basis
here's what she tweeted out with regard
to makia bryant so there's a woman named
brittany cooper
who said i'm not watching that body cam
footage always it's it's amazing how
many people will
preface a statement that is false by
saying that they won't look at the
evidence that their statement is false
i am not watching that body cam footage
but we see story after story of the cops
managing to take white men who threaten
them with guns knives and even ran their
cars
into police officers live yet somehow
anytime they engage with black folks
it's shoot first
and joy reid said this part right here
there's no statistical evidence this is
the case and you have to admire
the uh incredible temporary of people
who say i refuse to look at the evidence
but okay and then she followed that up
said
thanks professor crunk her tic-tock
videos broke my heart we decided we
wanted our audience to see her joyful
and alive
whatever happened to that house between
those girls an adult should have tried
to talk them down and help makia bryant
did not need to die
she was a child well you know obviously
you know whatever happened including a
person lunging another person with a
knife the cops
what are the cops supposed to do talk to
her while she's attempting to stab
somebody what is the preferred outcome a
social worker have been really useful
right about that moment when mckee
bryant was flying out that front door
and trying to stab that other girl
well done from from joy reid cornell
william brooks on cnn same thing
this was just a schoolyard fight so now
the left is full-scale engaged in
downplaying
deadly criminal activity to own the cops
it's pretty unbelievable
here is cornell william brooks on cnn
the question we have to ask ourselves
what if it were your daughter what if it
were your child
what if it were a member of your family
your neighbor uh
in a uh essentially a teenage fight a
schoolyard fight
uh certainly the facts will emerge but
we are
right to ask why can't we put the accent
on
life children's lives as opposed to
simply assuming
uh the best we can do is simply kill
another child we saw the body cam
footage it was just a schoolyard fight
though
it's just a schoolyard fight you know
like a schoolyard fight like that like
the one in which a 13 year old girl was
killed in cincinnati ohio that you don't
care about her name niara givens you
don't care about her
don't don't bother saying her name she's
just a statistic
this is a this is an incident she was
just a statistic and she's just a
statistic because she wasn't killed by a
white cop
it is truly unbelievable
so it didn't stop there bree newsome
who's a black lives matter activist
her tweets were flying around the
internet yesterday quote teenagers have
been having fights including fights
involving knives for eons
we do not need police to address these
situations by showing up to the scene
and using a weapon against one of the
teenagers
you all need help i mean that seriously
i mean
hell and romeo and juliet teenagers were
stabbing each other we didn't need
anybody to stop
that i mean the jets and the sharks are
going at each other routinely
knife fights it's just the thing
teenagers do i remember in my teenage
days
when old bob took off one of my ears and
i we laughed together had a beer
it's just something teenagers do cops
shouldn't be involved when teenagers
fight each others with knives
okay and this goes all the way up to the
white house jen sackey
who has been briefed on the situation
she says that this is just another
element of systemic racism it's always
systemic racism
systemic racism again the truly
systemically racist people are the
people who pursue policy
that is designed designed and known
to lead to more black loss of life that
would be systemic racism is if you
pursue a policy that you know
indubitably will lead to more dead black
people
and then you pursue that policy so let's
say that that policy removing all the
cops from areas of high crime which is
exactly what democrats are doing would
you call that systemic racism
looks a lot more like systemic racism
than the cops saving one black girl
by shooting a black girl who's
attempting to kill her here is
jen sackey engaging in some systemic
racism of her own here
the killing of sixteen-year-old michaela
bryant by the columbus police is tragic
she was a child we're thinking of her
friends and family in the communities
that are hurting and grieving her loss
and her death came as you noted just as
america was hopeful of a step forward
after the traumatic and exhausting trial
of derek chovin
and the verdict that was reached so our
focus is
on working to address systemic racism
and implicit implicit bias head-on and
of course to
passing laws and legislation that will
put much-needed reforms
into place at police departments around
the country it's unbelievable
a cop shoots a black girl to save
another black girl and the outcome is
systemic racism and implicit bias
from the white house from the white
house and then you have lebron james
the greatest and wisest of all americans
he's just
lebron james is a visionary i mean he
sure he's willing to take millions of
dollars from china and allow china to
basically commit whatever human rights
violations they want to commit and then
he'll defend china
sure lebron james doesn't know his ass
from his elbow when it comes to
actual statistics with regard to
policing or race in the united states
sure lebron james who's worth
approximately a billion dollars
goes around talking about how he lives
in existential fear of the cops which is
pretty incredible
sure lebron james doesn't really know
things
but here's the thing the media have
dubbed him a new wonder worker in
american politics they've dubbed him an
important figure
in american politics even though he
doesn't know things when i say that
lebron james doesn't know things
i mean it's pretty obvious he doesn't
know things i mean just last year he was
carrying around the autobiography of
malcolm x
and he was asked specifically what do
you like about this autobiography and
the tape is somewhat revealing
lebron james knows the slogans they
didn't know much beyond that so here's
lebron james explaining what he loves
most about malcolm x's autobiography
about a year ago
so you're holding the autobiography of
malcolm x along with alex haley i don't
know how far you are into the book but
what's your biggest takeaway so far
we're just a very um very smart man
very very very smart man and basically
um his words
in the in the 60s and uh
and what was going on is actually what's
going on today
still well it's that sort of brilliant
knowledge and
incredible wisdom and real insight about
race in america
that led lebron james to tweet yesterday
a picture of the cop
in this case the cop who just saved a
black girl's life
there's a picture of the cop and said
you're next all capitals you're next
with a little little hourglass next to
it
hashtag accountability
i didn't care about the circumstances
and kept out any of that all that
mattered it was white cop
black person got shot nothing else
mattered then he took it down because it
turns out that he looked like an insane
fool
because it turns out that when you
attack a police officer for saving a
black person
black person's life you look like a
damned ass
but lebron james didn't care about that
because lebron james doesn't care about
honesty all he cares about is the fact
that he's been treated
as a princely figure in american life
his entire adult life
he tweeted out he took it down here's
what he tweeted i'm so damn tired of
seeing black people killed by police
i noticed he's not so damn tired of
seeing black people killed by other
black people because he never tweets
about that he doesn't care about that
he doesn't care if the police save black
people by killing
black victimizers that doesn't matter to
him he's so damn tired of seeing black
people killed
by police i took the tweet down because
it's being used to create more hate
not because you're wrong not because you
look like an ass not because it was used
to create more hate oh
it was a hateful tweet you were
literally calling for the prosecution
of a police officer who just saved a
black woman's life lebron
he said this isn't about one officer
it's never just about one officer
it's about the entire system and they
always use our words to create more
racism
i am so desperate for more
accountability how about some
accountability for
your own words lebron how about some
accountability for slandering a man who
just saved a black woman's life
i hope he sues lebron out of existence
seriously
i hope lebron has to sign him a nice big
fat settlement check for that tweet
he would certainly deserve it but this
is lebron's america don't you understand
lebron is a thought leader the media
agree
with lebron the white house agrees with
lebron the circumstances of these cases
do not matter there's only one uniting
thread and that is that white america
and all of its systems are racist
and that any white cop who shoots a
black person even in the course of doing
his job or saving other black people is
bad
because that again is indicative of how
terrible the system is
we'll get some more of this in just one
second because this has some real
consequences in policy
and those consequences and policy by the
way will end with more dead black people
a study recently done between 2014 and
2019 the ferguson protests
the black lives matter movement has
resulted in somewhere between one and
six thousand more dead people mostly
black
in america's major cities over the
course of the last year murder rate in
america's major cities 34
major of america's major cities averaged
a 30 increase
in certain cities it was up almost 100
percent
in just a second we'll get to more of
this more of the left pushing the lie
that the police are the bad guys here
it's just about cop hatred and the the
whirlwind that is being reaped will be
sown
in terms of more innocent dead people
many of them black it's devastating
stuff we'll get to more of this in one
second first
let us talk about the fact that if
you're on facebook the big breach is
here facebook had 500 million accounts
exposed to cyber thieves according to a
retired fbi cyber crime expert
everything thieves need to take over as
the new owner of your home was in fact
leaked your name addressed personal
information
it's out there a thief can forge your
signature on a quick claim deed saying
you sold your home to him
and then he just starts taking out
credit against your home leaving you in
debt
or theoretically even having you evicted
you need to protect your home title you
can do it easily and quickly with home
title lock your home is certainly your
most valuable asset nobody's gonna steal
your actual physical home but they
certainly
can steal the title to your home and
then take out debt against it go to home
title lock.com register your address
see if you're already a victim then sign
up for 30 free days of protection during
this high
risk breach again head on over to
hometitlelock.com register your address
see if you're already a victim then sign
up for 30 free days of protection during
this high risk breach again
head over to home title lock.com use
promo code radio that is
hometitlelock.com
promo code radio you want to make sure
that you protect your most valuable
asset namely your home title go do it
right now at home title lock.com
promo code radio alrighty in just a
second we'll get to more of the anti-cop
agenda the cop hating agenda because
that's what this is this is not about
protecting black lives it's about hatred
of cops it is that simple
first as if you needed another reason to
join the daily wire i just want to
remind you if you're not already a
member you're missing out on candace
that's daily wire's new talk show hosted
by candace owens
this week's episode is a major truth
bomb candace dives right into the derek
chauvin trial verdict and gives her a
breakdown on george floyd's death plus
you're not going to want to miss this
week's special guest dana white
president
of the ultimate fighting championship
ufc it is the largest mixed martial arts
organization in the world the show
streams on fridays 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central only on dailywire.com
and get 25 off a new membership with
code canvas and get the audio podcast
canvas on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcast
so if you need some candid zones in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star review
if you like what you hear also i'm super
excited to announce this weekend we have
a brand new episode of the sunday
special it features an incredible guest
dave portnoy the founder and el
presidente of bar stool
sports it's a lot of fun dave is
definitely a rogue ceo
he's got a lot to say about business and
about sports go check it out this sunday
at dailywire.com or on my youtube
channel ben shapiro
dailywire members get access to special
bonus content from sunday's special
episode so don't miss out
join daily wire today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
the lie matters more than the truth you
wanna talk about systemic racism you
gotta talk about the fact that there are
so many people in positions of power on
the left who do
not give a damn if innocent black people
die
because they've decided to wreck the
cops that includes people like benjamin
crump
who can be found at every racial
conflagration in america he tweeted out
this is what he tweeted after the makia
bryant shooting quote
as we breathed a collective sigh of
relief today a community in columbus
felt the sting of another police
shooting as columbus police killed an
unarmed 15-year-old black girl named
makia bryant
another child lost another hashtag
hashtag justice for makia bryant
okay one problem she wasn't unarmed
but that's typical of ben crum ben crum
says they kind of crap all the time
every single case where ben crump jet
sets
he completely botches the fact pattern
and then the media pick up the fact
pattern they start mimicking
the lying fact pattern valerie jarrett
former chief of staff
to barack obama she tweeted out a black
teenage girl named makia bryant was
killed because a police officer
immediately decided to shoot her
multiple times
in order to break up a knife fight
demand accountability fight for justice
so now you don't just want cops to go to
jail for using excessive force like
derek chovin
you want cops to go to jail for stopping
the murder of another black person
so here's what i'm gathering all you
want is the cops in jail
that's all you just want the cops in
jail or you don't want there to be cops
at all
in fact some people are being pretty
clear about this hundreds of people
gathered
at ohio state university they gathered
outside the ohio union
they staged a sit-in inside the building
on wednesday to protest ohio state's
relationship with the columbus police
following the recent columbus police
killing of makia bryan first of all i
think that the columbus police if they
have the option
should just tell ohio state university
you're on your own enjoy
seriously have at it everybody we're out
organizers told the crowd the protest
was for police abolition
not reform they also called out the
university for not acknowledging
tuesday's shooting and said its
relationship with columbus police
makes students feel unsafe all the
students feel unsafe do they
imagine how unsafe they will feel when
there are no cops
because you know who's going to be the
chief target of crime if you get rid of
the cops at ohio state university
all the privileged kids going to ohio
state university that's who
a lot of laptops lying around in
backpacks at ohio state university
the protest came after bryant a black 16
year old girl in foster care was shot
and killed on the southeast side of
columbus on tuesday
protesters sat in silence inside the
ohio union for 16 minutes for brian's
age
in solidarity with her no solidarity
with the girl she was trying to stab
i've noticed but again the facts don't
matter
i mean it's it's really it's impressive
stuff it's impressive stuff and again it
has nothing to do
with anything except cop hatred that's
all it's just anti-cop hatred and
it'll be reflected in policy because
that is in fact the next
step is the reflection in policy which
is why
what you are seeing right now is the
biden doj cracking down
on the minneapolis police department so
the same minneapolis police
that just had the chief testify against
an officer and had several officers
testify against an officer
now the biden justice department has
announced an investigation of the
minneapolis police department
according to andy mccarthy fired up
minneapolis police department officer
derek shoving was convicted yesterday
afternoon
on all three homicide counts in the
racially charged droid george floyd case
with the inevitability of the morning
sun
attorney general merrick garland super
moderate guy announced this morning the
justice department is launching a
pattern or practice investigation of the
mpd
the pretext is that the evidence in
chauvin's case suggests the police
department as a whole
is driven by systemic racism this
despite the fact that some of the most
compelling testimony in chauvin's trial
came from mpd officials
you knew it was coming the obama
administration made a habit of
exacerbating tensions created by
police-involved incidents involving
black men
its justice department that exploited
such controversies to carry out a
federalization
of local law enforcement in conformance
with obama preferred progressive
policing
the feds don't go after the locals on
the individual case there will be no
civil rights criminal prosecution
of chauvin and the other ex-cops because
they don't have the actual material to
do so
instead the doj uses vague standards
democrats have written into civil law
amplified by the doj's gargantuan budget
for litigating against states and
municipalities to quote-unquote reform
entire police departments
as andy mccarthy wrote several years ago
the justice department civil rights
investigations that eric
holder was fond of announcing are not
like public trials they occur out of the
public eye
where feverish justice department claims
are not aired and scrutinized
more significantly they happen with the
air of extortion created by the nearly
28 billion dollars in funding
congress keeps giving justice every year
no matter how many congressional
investigations it obstructs
false statements its officials make how
much it politicizes law enforcement
during the obama administration there
were more than 20 major american cities
and their police departments
beholden to the obama justice department
they signed
consent decrees that basically allowed
the feds to
run the police departments to the great
detriment of the citizens of these
cities
who are then affected by the fact that
the police couldn't actually do their
job
seattle was snagged by the doj it's been
under a consent decree since the justice
department targeted it
in 2012 for a quote-unquote pattern or
practice of violations
allegedly including subjecting
individuals to excessive force
and uh crime went up because that's how
all of this works
meanwhile other cities are are looking
to crack down on their own police force
apparently chicago mayor lori lightfoot
is considering requiring a superior's
permission before you actually engage in
a foot chase
if if somebody has a gun and they're
running away from a cop
you'd have to call into your superior
and ask can i chase this person who is
dangerous and carrying a gun and running
around the city after having just shot
at
a moving car for example you have to you
have to call a superior
makes sense meanwhile in manhattan
they're no longer prosecuting
prostitution
as part of a nationwide shift
prosecutors local prosecutors and major
american cities have decided they're not
going to
prosecute low-level crimes we're about
to see an explosion
of crime in the major cities that we
haven't seen since the 1960s
it's going to be incredible it's going
to be horrifying for the citizen who
live the citizens who live
in these cities but if democracy is the
theory as hellman can put it
that the people deserve to get what they
want good and hard
then they're about to get it good and
hard i don't know a single cop who's not
thinking about quitting right now
every cop i know who's on a force is
attempting to get off straight duty
because why in the world would you be on
street duty when you could go and save a
black person's life
and then be condemned in the media and
consigned to the hell
of a of a country that turns on you and
calls you emblematic of systemic racism
for saving a black person's life
for volunteering to take a job in which
you are in the highest crime communities
to save innocent black people you are
now
called a member of a systemically racist
system
you're about to see an explosion of
crime you are and the consequences are
not going to be
as i keep saying over and over they
won't be held by ben crump the
consequences are not gonna
be be held by al sharpton the
consequences are never
going to fall upon wolf blitzer at cnn
or jason johnson over at msnbc or
jonathan k part of the washington post
those consequences won't be felt by
those people those people are doing fine
the consequences are going to be felt by
people who live in high crime areas who
just want to live their lives who just
want to run their business who do live
in everyday fear of criminality those
people are the ones who pay the price
because of the most maybe the most
robust finding in social science when
you get rid of the cops people die
it's already happening congressional
republicans right now they should be
pushing a bill to the fore
right now for increased funding for the
cops all over the country
because democrats are certainly pursuing
the opposite all right we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content coming up soon the matt wall
show airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure
to check it out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam scie events audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show